チャンネル登録者数が今988万人と今日
は12月18日
機ほどへ
こんにちははじめ社長ですちょっと今年
いけるから1000万人ちょっと不安なん
ですけどがまず行くか行かないかに微妙な
ところときってちょっと結構日々時々して
ます肇社長ですはいというわけで今日は
ちょっとね人と反省したいことがありまし
てまあまあチャンネル登録者数1000万
人入った後のお話をちょっとしようかなと
思っています意外と真面目にちょっともう
年代行くか行かないかは置いといてはじめ
1000万人入った後どうしようっていう
話をちょっと今日はしようと思いますまず
ですねあのファンの方とか視聴者さんに
よく聞かれるんですけどもねんか
結構言われてて実は昨日まだふときたんよ
ね昨日ふと何かはじめが急に
youtube やめてしまう気がして
不安になりましたできるだけで続けて
ほしいですてきたんですけど
いいよにしてるね結構言われててなんか肇
社長が1000万に行ったら辞めるんじゃ
ないかっていううわさうわさというか
なんか視聴者さんとか昔から観てる方とか
なんかちょっと
すごいねよくさせたねあの正直に言います
よ
1000万人入ったら
やめようとも思ってました
正直に言ってしまいました
すごいねー
俺は顔に出るんかなので顔に出てました
そろそろやめそうだなっていうの顔に出て
ましたええそうですいろいろ気持ちの変化
があったんですけども結構
ちょっと前までは何か
もう
いいんじゃないかと俺これいつまでやるん
だろうって正直思っちゃった時があってん
もちろん楽しいんですよ俺これいつ辞める
んだろうもうすぐ今28でしょもうすぐ
30歳になるしヒカキンさんでもたまに
話してこれあの俺たちどうなっちゃうん
だろみたいな頭考えたときに何か
1000万人で1つのキリの良い数字だっ
たんでまぁ正直
卒業ドロップアウトとか途中でやめました
とか姉が不祥事を起こして辞めた
ユーチューバーさんとがたくさんたくさん
って言ったらそう聞こえちらほらいたんで
俺の周りにもいたしてユーチューバーて
きれいに卒業した人といないんですよその
なんかそういう話をし課金さんとしてて
やーこれなんか
かっこよく終わりたいなみたいなキモとも
ちょっと出てきてて正直だったらもう
1000万人シャーンって言った時にもう
やめな卒業しますバーンステ卒業するのは
ひょっとしたら一番かっこいいのかなとか
思ったりしたんですよ
ちょっと前までは俺それが溜め込んでた
からかねすぐファンの方とか視聴者さん
から始め者数1000万でいたら辞め
ちゃうのみたいなものすごいきてて怖くて
誰がリープしたどこでその増資でたの
みたいなちょっと不安に駆られてたんです
けどよく気づきましたそう思っていたとき
もありましたそう思ってました正直その次
話すとねそう思ってたんですけどもまぁ
ティザー後12万人目前というか今年
行けるか行けないか微妙なところなんです
けど1000万人目前になって帰化議員
さんも今年して万人行かれてあの人はね
すごいよな人はですごいです1000万
去った後も何ら変わらずずっと言ってる
から日影さんに感謝ほんと1000万人て
も何も変わらず
ずっと頑張り続けてるんで僕は逆に心配に
なってました非課金様及びガス下いつまで
頑張るってすごいちょっと旋盤になってる
んですけどもあの地方をすごいすごすぎで
不安になります
[音楽]
でも僕と四角いなは違ってて俺あんなに
すごくないんですよ1000万人から卒業
するやめるって話だけど前提として
youtube すごい楽しいし動画作り
楽しいっていうのも絶対的にあるんで今
集まんないのすぐた全くないですけど
楽しいですよ
炎上させなければほど楽しいんで中別に
辞める理由がないになってこう最近思った
のとあの僕1000万円言った後の
夢とか目標がないんですよずーっとなん
ですけどずっとなんですけど僕なんか次の
ステージとかなくてめっちゃ情けないよと
に聞こえると申し訳ないんですけど今が
最高なんですよたまにテレビの出演とかさ
せていただいてうれしいした松井氏貴重な
経験あの芸能人とか綺麗な俳優さんが出た
中継所曲がります好きなアイドルとも話
いったことを頭だそういう貴重な経験が
非常にうれしいんですけども俺の目標は
テレビ選出とかでも全然ないし芸能人に
なりたいわけでもないし俺の家で行くこと
はここ9年 youtube 行ってきて
変わらず自分のしたいことを動画にして皆
に見てもらいたいの速攻疾患
9署恥ずかしい話でちょっとを書く悪いか
もしれないですね夢がないんですよね今が
幸せすぎてこれ以上ない1万人入って次の
ステップはって言われても
ないんですよなんかもちろん色々したい
ことがありますよもっとカードゲームとか
アニメとかゲーム好きな趣味に力を入れて
それを動画にできたら一番ハッピーだし
色々したいことはもちろんあるんですけど
もすべての到達点最終的な目標としては
こうなりたいっていうのがなくて今のこの
自分で動画作って youtube に
アップして有り難いことに皆に見てもらえ
てマジでこれだけなん仕様
あとモテたいですもてもモテたいとか有名
になりたいというのは少なからずの小継も
あるつあるそうなるためにももう俺は動画
を作りたいとか自分のやりたいことを動画
にしたいそんでみんなに見てもらいたいっ
て言うんですかなくてだから多分
止めても youtube を卒業しても
きっとなにかしらの形で映像制作とか
チャンネルの上とかに関わりたいとも思う
しわざわざ急いで卒業する必要もないかな
と思ってそうずギアのやめると表が卒業し
たいとしたいというか卒業するんだったら
止めるんだったらこのタイミングだろうな
みたいな感じで1000万人かなとは思っ
てたって感じです今度はの頭を辞めたいと
か無いですからね卒業したいとか方でも9
年近くやってきてるんでも長い長い歴史が
所がしくてもちろん苦しい買ったりつらい
こともあったし炎上してとっても傷ついた
こともありました本当に楽しいことも
嬉しいこともいっぱいあった日本一の湯
チューバーだった時もあったいろんな経験
をして今1000万人目前で改めて自分に
聞いてみるとあぁこうま座好きなんだって
いうを9年間もやって止めるぞの
タイミング目前に来て改めて
まずいっ
やりたいなって
思いました素直にっていう感じですせめて
ちょっとグダグダ話したんですけどもまぁ
要約させて頂きますと1000万人入った
後はとりあえずやめないと思いますこれ
ずっと昔から言ってるんですけども飽き
たら止めますこれもずっと持っチャンネル
登録画質いつでも関係なく辞めたくなっ
たらやめるって言うのは僕の中でずっと
あるんで1000万人言ってそうでやめ
ますということはないんですけどもこれも
ずっとやめたくなったらやめさせて
くださいっていうのはもうずっとあります
でも多分まだしばらく楽しい気はします
今年新時代ユーチューバーの48とかさ
com .とかさあ世銀9やるばたい子
たちともで動画撮ったりしたんだけど殺し
元気だし楽しいしまだまだ
一戦間にもし行けたとしてもまだいろんな
世界がその先にあるんだったら虹見たい
なって思います
なんでそれで1000万に行ったらあの
辞めないということと
1000万人いたその後
3冊をどうするのって質問に関しては何も
考えていないと言う
感じですいいこれで何もなくて何もない
やりたくないってことはないんですけどね
それをしたえっとはかあんまり慣れない
動画作ってた方が自分も楽しいして見てる
方も楽しんで頂けたら折れそうそれじゃ
ないんですよね正直えっどうしよっかな
マジでそうさあて次の手というか何か私を
出した方がいいのかなと思ってるんです
けどとまだ分からないが当初ながら
ユーチューバープロデュースとはしよっか
なば缶わかんないけどごめんもう俺は新万
円ピッターとどうなるか持つとわかんない
んですけどあとは止められないというか
卒業できない理由がもう1つあって
いろんな人
抱えてるなって思ったところがありますね
俺だけじゃないんですよ解禁戻ってきて
くれた第一君とか畑のみんなとかうううの
皆さんマネージャーさんと香って肇社長の
気持ちではい止めますパッツンで言ったら
結構困る人とか色んな人が苦しい思いを
するのかなっていうのはちょっと正直あっ
て自分の気持ちとか将来とか周りのことと
かいろんなことをひっくるめると
して間に入っても僕は9とりあえずやめ
ないんですなんだろ早くこの数字のレース
から脱却したよねヒカキンさん額で空とき
もちょっとほっ超杉原話せだし年内に
1000万に1回行かないかも結構の精神
的に何かだまだはしてて
落ち使うんですよ落ち着かないんですよ
本当はもうずつはそれもなんで辞めてたら
卒業したいって言っちゃった思っちゃっ
たっていう7かもしれないんですね楽しく
ワイワイ動画とってただけだったのに
気づいたらその数字のレースに巻き込まれ
ててなんか
追いかけられるような気分がずっとあった
のが苦しかったのかもしれないですまあ
それも楽しいんだけどね楽しいんですけど
今はとりあえずあの1000万人という
自分との戦いで得とずいぶんで首を絞めて
今年2021年は頑張っていこうと思い
ます本当にみんなありがとう
今年ももう少しなんですけど1000万に
入って会えくる
楽になりたいですこれはからちょっともう
皆さんにお願いするしかねぇぜひ皆さん
チャンネル登録よろしくお願いしますあの
離れてくすみたら統計みたいなチャンネル
の統計みたらさんネル登録せずに動画見
てる人まだ全然いたんですよまだまだ
チャンネル登録に僕のどこ見た人っ気こう
言うんで皆さん是非チャンネル登録お願い
しますじゃん
今年も水頑張る
じゃ
ん
ブー
4分